– Schau mal hier: Wer schenkt wem was?
Ich mache mal ein Beispiel:
Ich schenke dir einen Stift.
– Okay, jetzt ich. Ich schenke dir …
ein Wörterbuch.
– Vielen Dank. Das hast du gut gemacht.
Weiter geht’s: Was schenkst du
deinem Vater?
– Moment ...
Okay.
„der Vater“ ist ein maskulines Nomen.
Das Personalpronomen heißt „er“.
Jetzt brauche ich die Dativform für „er“ –
genau: „ihm“.
Also: Ich schenke ihm
ein Ticket fürs Theater.
– Prima!
Mach ruhig weiter. Was schenkst du deiner
Mutter zum Geburtstag?
– Ich schenke ihr eine DVD.
– Sehr gut. Und was schenkst du Nico?
– Guten Tag.
– Hallo, Mama.
– Hallo, Selma.
– Also, Selma, eine letzte Frage:
Wen lädst du zu deinem Geburtstag ein?
– „einladen“ ... Moment.
„einladen“ benutzt man mit Akkusativ.
Also: Ich lade dich ein.
– Sehr gut! Und vielen Dank.
– Ich kann jetzt Einladungen schreiben
für meinen Geburtstag.
– Wann hast du denn Geburtstag?
– In ein paar Wochen.
– Ach was! Hast du schon etwas geplant?
– Ich würde gerne eislaufen gehen.
– Eislaufen?
– Ja, das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich möchte es mal ausprobieren.
– Selmas Vater muss noch Ja sagen.
– Ach ja, wie geht es ihm denn?
Hat er den Job bekommen?
– Ja. Er arbeitet jetzt.
– Ah, sehr gut.
Ja, wir sind fertig für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Sie können stolz auf Ihre Tochter sein.
– Ich weiß.